okay four people joining us on the live
stream this is a meeting about
incremental enhancements to often
language with looks like four topics
today so let's start off with the first
topic word related functions unknown
word versus no data yes so the idea here
this is motivated by their function
synonyms and antonyms that we discussed
last week and the question is how do we
distinguish the fact that we don't
recognize a given word from the fact
that we do recognize that word but we
don't have data for that word so word
definition of food missing not available
seems quite reasonable missing not
available so what's the issue here so
well the issue is for a case like
antonyms you could say you know what are
the antonyms of red there aren't any
applicable antonyms because so that's a
no list yeah so right now the design we
have is that if it's a recognized word
but there's nothing no applicable
antonyms we give a null list if you say
what are the antonyms of foo it says
well there's no data associated with
that so we say missing not available we
don't recognize foo as a word and we
have no data about it so I'm sorry
you're saying antonyms of food you say
missing not available yes and if you say
antonyms of red it gives a null list and
the question is whether that's an
appropriate design or because the tricky
thing there is that the missing there's
two different kinds of missing one is we
have information about the word but
there's nothing applicable there's no
reasonable antonyms there's no synonyms
and the other is we don't have
information about the word well okay so
listen this this is probably wrong here
you should probably say missing unknown
word mmhmm yeah so there's the next
section down past part of speech has
what enemy value does which it the
default is
known entities for inputs that are not a
recognized word I don't know if we want
to say unknown entity for something like
we're definition we should sound known
would unknown word that's what I think
right because with weird definition it
was a little more straightforward
because if we have the word we have a
definition associated with it but for
synonyms and antonyms we may have the
word but there just may not be anything
applicable well that's okay then we
should give a null list I mean if we
know the word and we know that there
aren't any then just give a no list
that's fine I think okay well what's the
problem with that I mean is there is
there I mean okay so if you say antonym
of mm-hmm I would give a null list right
now so in in the in the future as rough
pages that's what we currently have as
the results in the case that seems right
to me I think that case is clear the
other case is they're not available
that's the one we wanted I think that's
wrong I think it should be unknown word
right right we have here just for this
discussion do you agree along with that
that's fine that's effectively what I
was saying in my reply earlier okay okay
so then we got to be good okay stick
around and is is um I I think it
wouldn't be bad for Nick to stick around
for a minute here as well I'll be here
also okay I think we have Francisco also
to talk about okay
we are in the subject to a phone number
physical address person name right
so we also have this notion of external
reference right which refers to I mean
that's a that's is that is that right
Alan that's something like the the you
know an orchid or something like that
Oh El Cid II yeah it could be but that's
what we were planning to call that is
external reference right what's what's
happened to wheedle of the last time we
were working on this it was external
identifier you are right you are right
you are right you're right I mean it
worries me a little bit that the word
external has become sort of a brand for
our external functions and things like
that for okay let me look at external
reference here we have some notes here
right
you
right so this is plugging into other
people's external identifiers
you
you
actually this is interesting in terms of
my um I mean what's what's happened with
the stuff by the way owned at the some
sideline because of other things going
on health aside cannot go back and
finish it off okay
is it knowing I'm just gonna add it
actually did one of my lists here
[Music]
you
is it no one um Oh actually already had
it
fancy that um I mean do we believe it's
fairly easy and whatever happened with
our bibliographic styles business its
with between Eric wasting and Erin also
both of whom have not been working on
that the last number of weeks okay I
think they were you know they were they
were starting to compile a list of what
we thought the canonical components of a
bibliographic reference would be and
also setting up and figuring out some of
the the external services we might use
to validate do is and other kinds of
identifiers in the cases where we needed
to do that okay
so we were starting here to talk about
personal names and so on actually
personal name I think is a better term
than person name
okay and this is what we had in mind for
[Music]
of exporting as a APA style citation etc
you're going like Clinton like I don't
know there was a agreement yes okay okay
all right so let's go back over here to
talk about um okay so there's the phone
number thing how we talked about phone
numbers separately and do we have Carlo
I think was the one who had actually who
has actually built the phone number
interpreter that we have today is that
correct I think so interpreter yes we
don't have Carlo here though perhaps we
should try to get him oh yeah I like so
let me let me send something okay let me
see so I'm just going here hold on one
second to the external um you know what
I shouldn't rename this I'm sorry excuse
me a second no okay let me go here
external reference so do we believe that
a phone number is an example of an
external reference we're not sure it
doesn't need to be it's it's a different
paper I wouldn't automatically think so
okay so what we believe is that a phone
number could either be I mean I would
suspect that what we want to do is have
you know you start with something like
this and is the canonical form of a
phone number then the thing broken into
you know area code country code you know
one blah blah blah blah blah
what makes sense there and then for I
mean then what we have
I mean dollar mobile number but I'm not
about to type here but dollar mobile
number is some Paula mobile phone gives
a phone number right so that would then
return that would then return one of
these phone number objects correct I
would expect that if we have a phone
number had something called mobile phone
was written that yeah right okay and so
then also interpreter of phone number
would return a phone number wrapper yes
did we manage to get Carlo or not just
lie to me okay
okay well while we're talking about that
let's some well we let's talk about okay
so the next one is I think personal name
and the next one is physical address I
mean maybe we should call that maybe it
should be geo address because we've got
fine geolocation right find your
location we'll take so I was doing I
missed her warned in the message that he
sent he can join right now okay okay so
that's an example of you know so what we
would want here is interpreter you know
we have interpreter of location that
returned what on earth is that
could you capture that solution and send
that in yes um and you should capture
the other of the screens here because
related to what a complete problem Wow
interesting
I don't think so I thought it was on a
production build but this is probably
corruption from some prototype mm-hmm
it's probably corruption of some
auto-completion try what I'm guessing it
is it's a corruption of my user learning
auto-completion
try based on something from the
prototype build okay okay so that is
very bad but it keeps on doing that
that's really weird
okay well that's what happens now oh my
gosh every time I click it's doing this
now let's try quitting the kernel so
Allah makes difference and restart by
the way we've got a bunch of background
noise which will be lovely to get rid of
here
thank you um okay so
oh my gosh it's back
that's the weirdest then well I'm gonna
restart I I don't want to be watching
this error message every every five
seconds um actually before I restart um
could you see if John is available
yep problem before so we could try to
debug it okay meanwhile
let's okay so we've got this notion of a
geo address what is the canonical
representation of that we started
talking about that before it's things
like you know city zip code etc now what
is it that we're going to use to break
addresses apart into that do we have
that technology Francisco can you
comment on that please
not really so what we have for example
with with applications we we use they
have their own parser and they probably
we could try to figure out from the
output they have more information like
for example the CT or some kind of
information related to that for example
I was talking about how they parse and
they parts for example separately the
country they place they have Anu the way
let's say also that there can be other
elements for example in rural zones you
have ways but you have blocks so so you
have different ways to took a far exact
address let's say besides the actual
number or some extra specification like
right yeah when I lived in Illinois I
had a lovely address that was an outside
of a town and it was just actually was
very weird it was a very weird address
um any case okay but so do we care about
breaking addresses into things like this
I think it would be more useful if we
can't do it but there should be a mode
in which if we cannot do it then we just
leave their address there as this like a
full specification with full strings and
- like that so if we can feel all the
other fields for example we don't have
in there was not sick coding all the
country only Lima for example until some
until a couple of years for example you
have sick sick codes in every place you
have postal codes you replace all the
zip code versus supposed to call postal
code you know and in the u.s. it's
definitely a zip code and I mean in the
u.s. there are things like FIPS codes
and things as well and a specification
of the census other places you know um
it is more like an external identifier
really right yes okay so you're saying
external identifier
it's you know it's a unique numerical
identifier for some kind of geographic
place counting other sorts of things
right it's not something that sort of is
part of a description of that thing it's
just another way of representing the
thing okay so is the name geo address
the right name
you
and Johnson's is here by the way okay
hey John I've got some stupid thing to
show you this is running eleven three
and look at this weird weird wood thing
oh gosh it's not happening anymore oh
sorry
okay so every time I try this that's why
I show up so I can make all the problems
go away by my presence right um okay
let's try typing it again okay so I type
interpreter Open bracket oh there it
happened again so you see I typed the
Open bracket and I get all these errors
coming out here I'm showing you this
because of to give you the opportunity
to tell me something to use to debug it
looks like it's miss creating see this
try file missing from layout yeah and
this is an 11-3 you said that's what I
said yes where is that try file I am NOT
a hundred percent for certain it could
get a few different places but is it
shared between different installations
or not it depends if it's in a pack word
not necessarily I mean I would like to
say that presumably this try file should
be handled with persistent value in some
way that would seem to me to be the most
consistent way to handle it well I'm not
for sure about this particular one but
my but one possibility is it might be in
a packet with interpreter functionality
which means that it's built as part of
the backlights if that's the case which
I don't know but I can try to run it
down and not further interrupt
discussion is it worth well to you to be
able to for me to leave this session
running so you can ask me to debug
something yes perhaps I don't think I
need to further interrupt your meeting
them I'll keep the session running okay
so it's gonna be generating garbage
somewhere poke back in a few if you know
what I should do to further debug it
using this session sure okay thanks
stick around whatever whatever you do um
okay so with respect to personal name
okay we know why we need this and that
just needs a pause afore the personal
name thing right
yes no I mean you know what we need to
do is say you know interpreter of
basically personal name of you know
whatever it is you know professor doctor
doctor you know Jane Smith whatever it
is PhD right and that has to turn into
something am I am i right okay so okay
so all right what are we going to
discuss with respect to phone number
don't we expecting phone number to
evaluate to something which is broken
the phone number the pieces or what are
we expecting to happen I would say that
if we yes it should be broken and then
these things should have methods and you
can extract the various pieces of it so
that it doesn't have to happen in real
time every time you try to extract
something the world countries have the
notion of area code not necessarily I
was going to commit that for example and
it might depend on different things for
example mobile numbers here doesn't have
any area codes but at least I think we
have like variable and England I used to
have in general the phone number the
phone number yes you have the we have
also here something like the Oh Oh 800
for free numbers so that they don't have
free an area code and well also there's
the there's the issue of the you know
like the one in the US it is a pun in a
sense that the one that you dial for
long distance in the US happens to
agree with the country code for the u.s.
see what I'm saying
like right in England you would dial
zero to get you know Oh 865 or something
to get a that would be like the within
the country code but that would be
equivalent to something like you know
plus four four - eight six five dot dot
dot but in country that would be 0 8 6 5
etc right having this broken into parts
is something interesting could we have
another function to build the number
depending on where you are I mean I'm
sure these things like send message and
so on deal with that in other words the
canonical form is the is the country
code plus the country code blah blah
blah isn't that correct
yeah that usually works um I just look
at something when you dial from a
landline you cannot use that form so you
have to use a short form where is you in
the place you are so that works always
from this from a mobile number okay so
for example there's this thing called
Lib phone number which I don't know
whether it's some gosh what is the demo
demo demo
okay so this has for example this has
the notion of country code and national
number
that's a separate issue which is oh this
whole kind of worms at mapping numbers
to carriers
you
yeah well look i think color is the
person who's really involved in doing
this and i don't think he's here so i
think we're gonna have to talk about
this a different time and i it is not
obvious to me where the phone number so
so to me there's two questions there's
what you know you enter it in some way
you
for for functions that simply call a
phone number you can feed it the
symbolic phone number object
there are obviously accesses that are
needed there's also the question of what
it formats like so for example just like
a date formats in a particular you know
if I if I say now for example all
formats in a particular way you know one
could imagine a silly thing with a
little picture of a telephone here that
gives the phone number um arguably with
some annotation to the country code if
that makes sense
arguably if you're not in that country
if your dollar geolocation country does
not agree with the what on earth is
happening here
that's really weird something is very
wrong here
anybody have any idea what's going on
there this is a call of Geo identifying
I think it's a country just worked
quickly for me something is very wrong
here
oh my gosh well okay I mean there is
something wrong with my installation
because we've got these other bugs but
yep okay and also copy Jason King please
okay okay in any case you know sorry you
were gonna say something francisco i
think it's a nice output for for the
phone numbers and probably for example
putting great area code or the country
code if you are in that area code and
country code for example before if
possible of course to identify the area
code right well i think the area code is
more of a mess at least in the u.s.
that's not so useful but well except an
old an old ii like me is proud of
knowing you know area code two one three
is los angeles or whatever else and when
people give me their phone numbers you
know it's like oh you know whatever but
it doesn't mean that much anymore
because you know it all got scrambled
because people get their cell phone at
some point in their life that comes from
wherever and then they keep the same
number okay but in any case okay so what
we need to do is is continue this with
carlo talking about the phone number the
thing that does phone number decoding
and i think we've got a path forward
with the question of exactly what these
sub parts are i think depends on what
the standardized ways that that works
are now with respect to the personal
name stuff that's in Turin
I mean we we that is obviously a
complicated area
[Music]
where people um yeah I see this a bunch
it's interesting there's a there's a
bunch of them of libraries out there for
doing this um
I'm sure it doesn't do a perfect job but
I'm sure it depends on the country and
so on and I'm sure there are cases where
it's simply ambiguous and to separate
the last name from the first name for
example I know in Latin American names
there's a whole I don't even know what
that even means each each component of
the name has a has a designation right I
mean you would call it give a name you
would call something I don't know if it
was in the sort of Soviet style it would
be you know patronymic etcetera etcetera
etcetera there must be I know there are
there are characterizations of that okay
so this is a separate this is a separate
discussion and a separate meeting but I
think you know this is the direction
we're gonna go on this what do we need
to decide in this meeting that we are
gonna have a phone number wrapper yes we
are
what else do we need to discuss here
right
so whether we need something else apart
from these three perhaps and I was
wondering about the relation with
entities because this that's two columns
and we had one on the left
okay so I think the answer to that is
this has the same relationship to
entities as molecule has two chemicals
that is that for example in the case of
personal you know okay so phone number
it might be the case that we have let's
say a company right which is an entity
and one of the things it has is a phone
number and that's one of these right now
the relationship between a personal name
you know there is a person named Charles
Babbage let's say right the personal
name will merely resolve that that
person is named you know Charles
I bellezza Babbage or whatever they will
not say which Charles Babbage it is but
we have also I think person is not the
right thing here necessary also we have
given name as an entity type so maybe I
understand I understand what you're
saying but given name so I see so the
question is name is is inside this
personal name all the name components
and today's core strings you can name
that maybe the spelling is not exactly
the same but you can associate that with
a given name entity and if you can know
you can have next us about your name for
example well okay so that is I I I don't
know how that works in different I mean
that is complicated when you're
translating names right because in you
know if you translate a name from I
don't know even Russian for example
right there could be multiple
transliterations and we don't have given
name entities I do not believe for
Russian names is that a true statement
now on values so there are some common
transliterations of course but not with
a native well I mean our given name so
your point is when you parse a personal
name do you map the components of the
personal name into entities or do you
leave in the strings I think the answer
is that there could be a component to
the personal name that is called given
name entity but I think that there also
wants to be a just a pure given name
which is a string
I'm making sense because I think that
there will be but first of all you know
there are clearly given names that
aren't entities for us right
I mean and may have a different spelling
or whatever well different spelling is a
weird thing I mean so I mean
transliterations is one issue um but I
mean like like for example I think you
know like my name okay has has multiple
common spellings right so that name is a
different name from that name as far as
I'm concerned
and okay so then then the issuer's okay
then there's that right and okay so that
is an interesting issue so in other
words if you say right so there's the
given name which is on some you know
passport or whatever and then there is
the the nickname so to speak which is a
different thing or the common name it
we've we've addressed this actually in
my people database developed like 20
years ago I've tried to address this as
CEO although I have to say it's it's
it's that aspect of it is definitely
falling into disrepair
so I'm saying so in other words that the
person might be referred to as Steve
Jobs for example even though his legal
name was Steven jobs making sense
refused to accept some name because I
mean somebody could have a name taken
from some modern movie that we have you
know famously you know the first name
moon unit was used at some point and we
are quite certain that moon unit is not
in the given name entity list so yes I
agree which is why I'm saying there
should be a given name as a string and
also if it can be mapped to an entity
their map eternity I think we need a
separate meeting about this because it's
gonna be all involved with a pausing of
personal names right you know because
the main issue here is so the big issue
is canonicalization right by the way
that might also be an issue for phone
numbers as well
right I mean that's it that's you know
that is something we would want to
achieve as canonicalization because we
would want to figure out you know in
this list of phone numbers is this the
same phone number I mean you know for
example if you're trying to maintain a
Do Not Call list you want to know oh
well I actually you know that phone
number that just came in and said it
wants to be the do-not-call list is the
same number as whatever makes sense all
right so I think this needs to branch
off into separate meetings okay
Sushma did you get yep I did okay do we
need anyone I think we should have Kiara
unless she says she shouldn't be there
okay for the pausing stuff I think we
also need who knows about the geo coder
oh the other people we need you know we
have obsessively talked about some
aspects of this name cracking in the
machine learning group okay yeah I don't
know you know we should get some
representative from okay yeah okay okay
let's move on here okay okay thanks guys
okay okay so the two remaining topics
one is about reviewing documentation of
additions in the order functions and the
other one is the discussion about I
think in stories I want to talk about
that one okay so yes so the second line
that's new yes so because now there are
three missing as moving pieces there
it's kind of difficult to explain okay
so there's a secondary sort is basically
what you're saying yes it's a yes the
sort of the F of the mapped F is wrong
we speak
but to have to stress that the result is
a steel elements of list and not
elements of F on the list I think it's
okay that says that according to the
ordering function P yep seems okay to me
okay good bye I assume uses the same
very similar yes so yes so those are
their two new functions and those are
still futurist which ones reverse swap
by an ordering by exactly okay
well I'm sure this is fine I mean if it
just corresponds to yeah okay and
ordering by let's just take a look at
that oops happened I must type it order
rain okay by the way what are there see
also did you knit them at that level yes
I did them I said okay yes but nothing
guide pages that's the last topic there
okay okay so okay so I'm okay with these
few tries in these should I do it okay
if I'm doing guide pages stuff anyway
okay so let's see we need to consult my
strange pet elephant here um let's see
River sort wow it's not a popular
function and the Sun okay let's see
where is it discussed to sort where is
it am I lost her to sort by so perhaps
after sold wine and wears ordering
discussed yeah yeah yeah yeah I don't
have a whole line for this thing perhaps
saying to half reverse thought 20 result
by together and we do them after sold by
now let's not do that I think this isn't
the primary place for reverse is it
now reverse is under lost interpolation
[Music]
[Music]
I mean I have half a mind to put those
two under there yeah you know what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna do this does that
make sense okay okay now ordering by so
let's see where is ordering Wow um
claims it's under listen I feel I should
not see where it is there let me see is
it here
well for some reason my eye system I am
my machine for finding references has
failed me on that particular word let's
just see yeah see where is that
permutations what is it relevant to
permutations
it's an industrialization but ordering
by I don't think it's it's foreign here
okay
so then it's relevant to where is all
right on this page ordering there we go
Wow I mean it's ordering by more
interesting than ordering sort of is its
yeah it's a degree of flexibility no no
but I understand but is it more useful
because ordering is not that commonly
used I mean if I say ordering of a CB d
for example okay I get that so or thing
is used sometimes to say what's the
position of the largest or the position
of the smallest I never remember to use
it for that how does it use it for that
so so you would say for example ordering
minus one and that's the position of the
largest right and now we thought hearing
buy one can say give me the position of
the longest string for example if you
hear string length honestly that's a
really obscure thing if I saw that in a
piece of code it would just be I mean
it's just completely obscure I think I
just wrote a thing actually for the
function repository which is a you know
it's basically a
position lodgest basically which is this
i mean honestly that would be you know
to me that's a more useful function you
know position largest position largest
by I think I just wrote these for the
function repository as it turns out well
this is equivalent to ordering
I mean it's maybe a matter of a name but
or the rings in there for so long I
understand that but I mean ordering does
the whole thing whereas position largest
would return just the position you know
would would do this I mean this is
really obscure in my opinion I favor the
use of something like ordering a
position largest I think that's a good
function for us to have as a sag just
implemented a version of the function
repository but okay so that the the the
question that you asked is where should
ordering by Beyond guide pages right so
I yeah we could put it here next to
order where is ordering even on here I
was following up I don't think it's on
the side yeah it was it wasn't it
another page to what if that yeah this
one so yeah because this is referring to
positions basically so there is this set
of position for a related you know I
mean I'm not wild about putting it on
this page I think it's some
[Music]
in the cycle that's an awful lot of not
very relevant functions pub what should
this go look I really support the idea
of this position largest position
largest by function function depository
I I think it's built-in functions
because I use them but some frequency I
mean I I happen to employ tip for the
function repository but I think it's
it's something that should be promoted I
mean it takes a bit more effort okay
where are we gonna put this what is the
what is ordering by related to the
documentation for example mentions sort
by because it's so ordering is to sort
world ordering by is to sort by indeed
alright let's look at the page which is
about which has sort by alright how long
yes Sandra livestream is pointing out
correctly that ordering does not
restructure a list it simply gives an
ordering of that list I agree
well it did it's only a part where do we
have it we didn't know it isn't on that
page right so um what is the right place
for it that is a tutorial that's not
relevant at all um Wow
I don't know that we have a place for
this
where are things like the oh gosh what's
it called that the indicator function
type things that are not what are they
called
I have a good solution the task T core
design or see whether you have a
suggestion for this I don't have a good
suggestion right now um I want to get on
through our last item here um key
distributor yes so so this is a mixture
of three different problems we'll have
discussed before and and the code that
you have the end those subsections you
have seen it already okay so given an
array and list of keys for each level
return nested Association right yes so
that's a key distribution function now
we have discussed how to do that or
something similar in data set so that we
pass an array and the key separately by
the way it's critical now working on
data set we had a meeting recently with
tally to learn how to interact with the
code and but but crystal working on on
the formal phone networks okay we really
need to get that going
okay
[Music]
okay okay so a possibility here is to do
do is to do this via data set because if
we had their notation to add a keys in
data sent and then normalize that would
be basically everything in the indirect
but that's very indirect I mean this is
basically taking an array and labeling
things in the array and we had been
calling it key distribute this is right
where the idea is let's look at your
syntax thing here so this is a
generalization we discussed this in a
session that would be a it's an effigy
type in generalization such that for the
case we have here F will be rule and G
would be Association
I see where it puts so it's a map
thready like thing like thread the
nesting is is due to a factor that will
go deeper and deeper to deeper levels
and the threading is what you see
okay so the issue here is if you
evaluated a code section to come on that
there's a certain certain relativistic
character to this example okay
in any case and obviously if it doesn't
match the shapes then there's an issue
but but this is what I think it should
be doing I mean this is this key
distribute of those keys across the
array yeah I mean this is right that's
exactly right
now your issue is your idea here is to
be able to have an F and G there
wouldn't want users to use this more
general function always but you know
it's a class I mean it'd be okay and
what's the relationship with not indexed
well map indexed is leading in I see
that's getting pretty obscure here we
just had to find motivation for
alternative names
what's wrong with key distribute it to
me it's fine
to me it's fine somebody have an
objection to it well we have distribute
and the question is whether this is
really like distribute and it's slightly
different but it it's not completely
ridiculously wrong for that now what
happens if you want at some level to do
if you want to just maintain nan to not
have to put keys at some level to
maintain it as a list how do you do that
do you say automatic at that level do
you do the following do you say key one
key to you know for that level Baba kama
automatic comma and then you know K 1 K
2 etcetera etcetera etcetera the third
level - I'm saying yes or perhaps it
should be no automatic could be
interpreted as use not integers yes I
agree I agree and then you could imagine
some other constructors for things there
now if if there are if you are over
filling with keys
it doesn't object it will just use it
will just slice off the keys that it is
being I mean in other words if I said
key distribute alphabets easy comma
range of five right thank you for okay
so that didn't do the right thing I mean
but I think that should just slice off
the first layout for that right yeah I
think you can over-over
so in other words the algorithm is
you're taking I mean in other words in
fact there's more than just the F and G
functions because what there is is the
index or into that first element Oh
actually you know so this case which I
just did is could be argued to be that's
a degenerate case as well because really
it is this right the broken both ways
but both of those should work yes yes I
mean the code is now expecting to have
exactly the proper animations but that's
what we can handle all this this cases
okay
all for example if you don't specify
enough levels of keys it will just go
you know just stop doing it little none
it so to speak okay so let's just talk
for a second about the infantry
functions I I feel like the key
distribute things should be in this
order I mean I think it should be keys
first and let's see I think it should be
keys first
I think so it's easier to remember even
that it's going to go to associations
yeah okay fair enough
um okay so keys awry now this
generalization that you want to do I
mean do we actually care about this
generalization not much not much me I
said I have an example that was
polynomials and things it but it's kind
of come well at the end of not at the
end of the previous subsection there I
think that at the end of three levels we
look here in a combinational so I'm
using x and plus
no it's hopeless it's hopelessly bizarre
and complicated in my opinion
okay who can start with with the key
distribute I think so key distribute
that and I was thinking of having a
third argument which is a level spec but
of course we can also control that by
just having the proper length of the
first document yeah it's about a way to
do it I mean and if you want to you know
go down borrow down a bunch of levels
before you start doing this then use
nuns nice okay I think this is a nice
function I think we should do it okay
and I think I'll think we're at time
here you see so thank you all very much
thanks to folks on the livestream and
talk to you all soon